de nouveaux éléments dévoilés ce
dimanche suite à la 17e attaque
terroriste contre les forces de l'ordre
en sept ans deux jours après le drame de
rambouillet les informations sur
l'assaillant décédé lors de la taxe se
précise
le procureur national anti terroriste
donne plus de détails sur l'attaqué
perpétrée par djamel gore chaîne à 14h25
le 23 avril après s'être dirigé vers une
salle de prière djamel gorgen se rend au
commissariat de rambouillet et attaque
au couteau une policière qui décèdent
des suites de ses blessures
le parquet antiterroriste et très
rapidement saisi c'est la radicalisation
de l'agresseur paraît peu contestable la
présence de certains troubles de
personnalité a pu aussi être observés
à ce titre son père a souligné que son
fils avait adopté pratique rigoureuse de
l'islam
d'un autre côté il a également mentionné
différents troubles de comportement
qu'ils avaient pu remarquer chez son
fils au début de l'année
un de ses proches avait noté un
comportement dépressif de la part de
djamel corps chaîne c'est pourquoi en
février dernier il a sollicité une
consultation psychiatrique son état
n'avait malgré tout pas nécessité
d'hospitalisation ou de traitement suite
à l'analyse de ces postes facebook
les enquêteurs ont également pu
constater une évolution des messages
publiés au cours des derniers mois
d'abord strictement centré sur la
religion
ces publications révéler à compter de
l'automne 2020 une adhésion à une
idéologie légitimement la violence
contre ceux ayant enfoncé le prophète le
24 octobre 2020 quelques jours après
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit l'auteur
s'associait une campagne de soutien aux
prophètes face aux offenses qui lui
seraient faites depuis l' attaque cinq
personnes proches de l'assaillant dont
son père ont été placés en garde à vue
les investigations se poursuivent selon
le procureur pour identifier les
complices coauteur ou inspirateur de
l'acte terroriste ayant causé la mort de
la policière
des investigations
lyon mené en relation étroite avec les
autorités tunisiennes